>> All right, let's figure it out.
>> well, so, first off, I think the first thing,
if I'm right is. So, is the following statement true?
Once we know four of them are right, we will
stumble onto the right answer when we do the neighborhood.
>> Well, so, okay. So, that's a good
idea. We could, actually, do one more step.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And see what happens. So yeah, because,
in this particular case, that because of the
fitness function is the way that it is,
the number of correct bits. There's always a neighbor
that is one step closer to the target.
>> Right.
>> So we're always going to be incrementing as we go.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So this is a very friendly fitness function.
>> It's only, only a global optimum.
>> Right. So, do you want to do that? And then maybe we
could talk about how we could have been even more clever? So, let's
just pick the first one. Okay. And so, now we have to do
the fourth one, so it's 10110, and then the fifth one is 10101.
>> Okay. All right, so this if is x and these
are the neighbors of x, these are the scores. And it turns out that
one of them actually has all five matches. So that was in fact the
pattern I was thinking of. Here, just to prove it 10110. And if we now continue
the search from here, all the neighbors are going to be worse, obviously.
>> Right.
>> So, how could we have figured out the
sequence without that extra information that I just gave you?
>> Well, if we look
at the two that have four, we can basically just see that where the, the, they
must have three in common. Which they do.
one, the first, the second, and the last one.
>> Okay.
>> And each is off by exactly one. So, that means
that, well, since I know the answer, I know that you just
take one, you just take one from each. So either they
have to both be ones or they both have to be zeros.
>> All right, and so do
we know that the 01 doesn't work? We probably know that the 01 doesn't work.
>> because that, then the answer would be 10000, 10000.
>> Which we already have.
>> Which is exactly, we already know is a three.
>> Right. So then it has to be 10110, which in fact it is.
>> Which it was.
Cool
>> Right, so this was in fact a very nice fitness function.
and, and, and, you know, it seems to me that we had
a, a, nice little advantage here in that we really understood the
structure of our space. But if this were a 5000 bit sequence, where
the fitness function was some weird thing. Where, in fact, we didn't
even know what it was. We just knew that there was one.
Then, that would've been a whole lot harder. actually, here's a question
for you, Michael. If I had told you, if I had given you
this, but I haven't, didn't tell you what the fitness function was.
Just that when you gave me a sequence, I evaluated it for you.
>> Uh-huh.
>> We wouldn't have been able to do any of the stuff that we
were doing. I mean, we'd still be able to do it, but we wouldn't have
been able to jump ahead. Like, we just, like we could've done with those
two that were four, because we wouldn't
even know what the maximum fitness value was.
>> Yeah, we would have to done this last
step to, to find that one of them has
a score of five. And then we would have
to done that step again to make sure that
there wasn't anything locally better than five, because we wouldn't
of known that if we didn't have a kind of semantic
understanding of the fitness function. But, but the rest of the
algorithm was perfectly implementable without knowing that, right? All, all that
you were basing your decisions on was, you gave me
bit sequences, I gave you scores, and you used those to
figure out what next bit sequence to ask. It, it didn't
use the fact that the fitness function had a particular form.
>> That's right. That's right.
>> Now, this wouldn't,
this particular problem is very, very well behaved, because it has
one global optimum, this bit sequence that has a score of five.
Nothing else had a five. And once you're at five, and,
and no other bit sequence actually could you be stuck. Right, so
it was always the case that you could always get closer
to the target pattern, so your score can always go up. But,
in general, that's not how things work. That you may actually be
able to get stuck in local optima and we need a way
of dealing with that.